aujourd'hui j'ai un aujourd'hui j'ai
même des cadeaux à vous offrir une vidéo
qui en partenariat avec the skies alors
je vous rassure c'est pas du tout une
vidéo sponsorisés il n'y a pas d'argent
par l'échangé d'argent c'est vraiment
une vidéo pour vous faire des cadeaux
alors je vous explique le principe
[Musique]
oh
avec lequel on s'est dit que ça serait
cool de proposer à tout le monde des
accessoires
monsieur coué pour embellir votre
smartphone est toujours proposé des des
choses toujours plus sympa et toujours
plus sexy sur le coup j'aurais pu vous
offrir l'enceinte personnalisé de
monsieur gros mais bon franchement je
crois que je vais la garder pour moi non
aujourd'hui c'est pas d'un simple
monsieur greu c'est pas l'amplificateur
c'est pas la petite batterie
aujourd'hui je vous offre un cadeau
unique votre coque deux portables
monsieur greu tout simplement
alors l'idée de la coque monsieur reus
et je suis ton père c'est à dire c'est
le vieux téléphone le gros vieux
téléphones des nobles sol est qui parle
à un nouveau smartphone et qui lui dit
la fameuse réplique de dark vador à luke
skywalker
donc voilà donc c'est une coque est
forcément dans la thématique star wars
c'est moi qui l'ait fait je me suis
appliqué avec mais avec mes petits
doigts au milieu là je sais pas si je
sais pas si on voit bien au milieu j'ai
fait une ennemie l'étoile noire pour
faire le luron du cadran téléphonique du
vieux téléphone il ya des petites
étoiles un peu autour ça se voit bien
comme ça mais il ya des petites étoiles
bombasse la guerre des étoiles je suis
ton père et puis bien évidemment le
petit logo monsieur grrrr
[Musique]
oh
jorat en tout 20 coq a gagné je vous
invite à participer au concours en
concours qui a lieu pendant dix jours
c'est à dire à partir du 15 juin 2010
est jusqu'au 25 juin
vous avez donc cette plage de 10 jours
pour valider votre participation pour
suivre le procès ce qui est inscrit en
bas d'un description vous participez et
les résultats seront donnés sur mon
compte twitter juste un petit coup
d'oeil son site de the gates pour voir
si votre smartphone est compatible avec
les offres des coques personnalisées
font parler de ce qui est très très
rapidement il vous offre la possibilité
de faire des coques personnalisées
alors moi je suis très content parce que
du coup bon j'ai fabriqué mais petit coq
et puis je vous l'offre
mais on peut aussi personnaliser pas mal
pas mal de choses un pic notamment cette
enceinte alors moi je suis super content
de ça parce que j'avais une enceinte peu
anciennes et ça je vais pouvoir le
transporter partout avec moi alors tu
crées tu es un peu sexy j'ai d'un côté
monsieur re mais bon pour avoir la paix
des ménages
j'ai aussi fait madame dreux de l'autre
côté ce qui fait que c'est une enceinte
de coupe
voilà mais je vais la garder pour moi
faut pas le dire à madame grossetête
enceinte je la garderais uniquement pour
moi voilà donc voila un petit peu ce
partenariat avec the guys il ya d'autres
produits coucher aussi si ça vous
intéresse assez l'amplificateur iphone
vous mettez votre iphone dedans ça nous
amplifie le son ça évite de transporter
en syntonie c'est dans votre poche ça
c'est cool et autre élément
indispensable pour tous marie parent
festival là dans les jours qui viennent
c'est le petit chargeur vous branchez
votre téléphone dessus vous avez les
chargeurs ça vous fait une recharge
complète et ça c'est super cool
voilà que pour cette jolie petite
sélection que j'ai fait chez heuliez
merci d'avoir regardé la vidéo j'espère
que ce petit cadeau vous plaît un et que
vous allez faire partie des gagnants
pour remporter la coque the gayz
monsieur groupe et moi je me suis fait
un grand plaisir à faire ce petit visuel
tout en sachant qu'il ya un nouveau
savoir s'il sort à la fin de l'année
donc là pour le coup on est vraiment
raccord merci à très bientôt et puis que
le meilleur ou la meilleure gagne
ciao
[Musique]